Welcome back to recitation.
In this video I'd
like us to work
on the following application
for spherical coordinates.
So what I'd like
us to do is find
the gravitational attraction
of an upper solid half
sphere of radius a
and center O, that's
the gravitational attraction
on a mass m naught at O.
So the m naught is sitting at
O, we have a solid half sphere
of radius a and
center O, and we want
to find the gravitational
attraction of the half sphere
on the mass.
And we're going to
assume that the density
delta is equal to
the square root of x
squared plus y squared.
So why don't you pause the
video, take a little while
to work on it, and when you
feel good about your solution,
bring the video back up,
I'll show you what I did.
OK.
Welcome back.
Again what we're going
to do is we're going
to do an application problem.
And what we have is we
have the solid half sphere
of radius a and
center O, and we want
to know the gravitational
attraction of it
on a mass m naught.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is draw a picture, just so
I can get myself oriented.
The easiest thing
to do-- obviously,
when I'm going to try
and figure this out,
I'm going to use
spherical coordinates.
I have an upper
solid half sphere,
so that should tell me spherical
coordinates will be good.
And the easiest way to deal
with spherical coordinates
is obviously to choose
O to be the origin.
So I'm going to have m naught
sitting right at the origin.
And then I'm going
to have-- oops,
I should write that
somewhere else.
Maybe, well, I'll
just leave it there--
and then I'm going to
have the solid half
sphere, which I'm going to
just draw sort of like this.
Maybe that doesn't look
like a sphere to you.
But we have the
solid half sphere
and it's exerting a
force on m naught.
And if I want to
know the force-- how
we denote the force in
lecture was the components
were the x-component
of the force,
the y-component of the
force, and the z-component
of the force.
And so I want to point out these
are not partial derivatives.
This is the standard notation
you use for force in this case,
and so these are not
the partial derivatives.
They're just the
x-component, the y-component,
and the z-component.
And if you notice,
this upper solid half
sphere-- because of
where m naught is,
the x-component and the
y-component of the force
are 0 based on symmetry.
So all I really need to worry
about is the z-component.
I'm only really interested
in one component of the force
and it's the z-component.
Because the other two
are going to be 0, just
by the symmetry of
this solid half sphere.
So I really only
need the z-component.
So what I have to do, in
order to calculate the force,
is I have to figure out the
magnitude and the direction.
So let's write down
the two components.
These were given
to you in class.
So the magnitude is going
to be equal to G m naught
dm divided by rho squared.
So this was given to
you in class already.
So G is some constant; m
naught is the mass you have;
dm, we have to determine
a little bit about it;
and then we're dividing
by rho squared.
And the direction--
because I'm only
interested in the z-component--
the direction is just z,
but then I want to make sure
that the direction component is
z divided by rho.
The full direction is
[x, y, z] divided by rho,
but I'm only interested
in that last component.
So the z-component
is just z over rho.
If that confused
you, I just want
to remind you that
you had [x,  y, z]
over rho is the full
direction of the force,
we're just pulling
off the z-component.
So what we're going to
be trying to figure out--
we need to integrate the
product of these two things,
but I need to figure
out what dm actually is.
So let me remind you also
what dm is and then we'll
put it all together.
dm, to remind you, is supposed
to be the density times dV.
And the density in this
case was square root
of x squared plus y squared,
that's just equal to r.
So it's just r*dV.
So there's a bunch
of little pieces
and now I have to
put them together.
So if I want to determine
the full attraction
in the z-direction, because
the other two are 0,
I just need to do
this triple integral.
I'll figure out my
bounds momentarily.
I'm going to leave a lot of room
to write my bounds, because I
always run out of room.
And then I just
need to integrate
G m naught divided by rho
squared times z divided
by rho times r dV.
Actually I won't even
do the bounds yet
because I have to
change everything
into polar coordinates.
So let's figure
out how to do that.
What is z in polar
coordinates? z
in polar coordinates we
know is rho cosine phi.
So I'm going to
have a G m naught--
I'm going to keep this
rho cubed right here--
and then I'm going to
have a rho cosine phi.
r is rho sine phi, so I'll
just put another rho, and then
a sine phi.
And then dV is rho squared
sine phi d rho d phi d theta.
So what I'm going
to do here is--
I have to add in a rho squared,
so I'm just going to cube this.
And another sine phi, so
I'm going to square that.
And then I'm going to have
a d rho d phi d theta.
Hopefully that wasn't too scary.
But the z is my rho cosine phi.
The r is a single rho sine phi.
And then dV includes a
rho squared sine phi,
so I put a cubed here
and a squared here,
and then d rho d phi d theta.
So now I just have
to integrate, so I
have to figure out my bounds.
So we're integrating
first in rho.
And rho, it's a sphere- a
half sphere of radius a.
It's a solid half sphere.
So I'm just integrating
from 0 up to a.
And then phi-- because
it's a solid half sphere,
phi is starting at 0
and it's going down
until it hits the xy-plane.
And so that's pi over 2.
We know we start at 0, we go to
pi over 2 when we go a quarter
turn, basically.
When we go 90 degrees, right?
So we go 0 to pi over
2, and then theta--
once I've taken my rho and
I've gone up as far as I can,
and I've gone down this way, I
have to rotate it all the way
around-- and so theta is
actually going from 0 to 2*pi.
All right.
So this is my full
integral I have here.
And now let's do
some simplifying
before we integrate.
Notice I have a rho cubed
in the denominator here
and a rho cubed in
the numerator there.
So when I integrate in rho,
I only have this single rho.
When I integrate that rho,
everything else is fixed.
So I integrate that rho, I
get a rho squared over 2,
and I evaluate it
at 0 and a and so I
get an a squared over 2,
as integrating this part.
I'm going to pull
all that to the front
and then write what I get next.
Let me write what I get next.
I'm going to have a G
m naught as a constant.
I'm going to be multiplying
by a squared over 2
from the rho integral.
And then I have
2 more integrals.
Integral from 0 to 2*pi.
And the integral from 0 to
pi over 2 of cosine phi sine
squared phi d phi d theta.
So how do I integrate
this in phi?
Looks like it's going to
be sine cubed phi over 3.
Let me just double check.
The derivative of that is 3
sine squared phi cosine phi.
Yes.
So, this is going to be
sine cubed phi over 3
evaluated at 0 and pi over 2.
This inner part is.
And so let's see
what we get there.
Sine of 0 is 0.
Sine of pi over 2 is 1.
So I just pick up a
1/3 from this integral.
So now I'm going to
pull that out in front.
So again, the thing
I've written down here
is just the integral of this.
So I just get a 1/3 out of that.
Let me double check.
Yep, sine of pi
over 2 is still 1.
Good.
So I get a 1/3 out of that.
That's a constant.
So I'll pull that to the front.
And then notice
what I'm left with.
I'm just integrating
0 to 2*pi of d theta.
Well that's just 2*pi.
So I've got a 1/3
from the inside one,
times a 2*pi from
the outside one.
So I just end up getting
2*pi times-- or 2*pi over 3,
because there's my 1/3 also--
times G m naught a squared over
2.
And if I simplify
that, I just get
G m naught a squared pi over 3.
And so if I want to know
the force of this solid half
sphere acting on the mass
m naught, where the mass is
positioned at the center of the
base of the solid half sphere,
it's going to be exactly
the following thing.
By symmetry, the first
two components are 0
and the last component is this
G m naught a squared pi over 3.
And so that's my final solution.
Let me just take us back and
remind us where we came from.
So we wanted to find the force,
the gravitational attraction
of this solid half sphere that
had a radius a, was centered
at O, and had mass m
naught sitting at O.
And so we were interested
in drawing the easiest
picture possible.
We're going to put
O at the origin,
so m naught's at the origin.
Then we have a solid
half sphere of radius a.
So this is-- you know, if
I come all the way out,
my radius length is a.
And I gave you the
density was equal to r.
So we know-- the force
we're interested in,
F sub x, F sub y, F sub
z, from the picture alone,
we see F sub x
and F sub y are 0.
So we really only
need the z-component.
So you know how to
find the magnitude
and you know how to find the
direction of the vector field.
The reason that you've
divided by rho here, just
to remind you, is
that the direction,
you want it to be a unit vector.
And so this is what
makes it a unit vector.
And so the direction part
that I'm interested in
is the z-part.
So it's z over rho.
And so all I need to do
is take the z over rho,
multiply it by the magnitude,
and replace the dm by what it
is in terms of the volume form.
And in terms of the volume
form, it's the density times dV
and so in this case
it's just r*dV.
So I made all those
substitutions.
And then all I had to do
is do a lot of replacement.
And that was kind
of the messy part,
and then the
integral's fairly easy.
So the messy part is z I
replaced by rho cosine phi.
r I replaced by rho sine phi.
And dV I replaced by rho squared
sine phi d rho d phi d theta.
And then I just
have to figure out
what the bounds are for the
half sphere, solid half sphere.
And then I integrate.
And the integration
is all ultimately
one step at a time,
single variable.
And they were all
fairly simple integrals.
So in the end, we see that
your mass m naught sitting
at the origin, the force exerted
on it by this solid half sphere
is 0, 0 comma G times m naught
times a squared pi divided
by 3.
All right, that's
where I'll stop.